I think chrissy teigen should lean in to
being accountable at this point because
she's probably not but all twitter did a
lot of twitter thing she has so just
lean into it and after our legend get
out and be like we're just ordinary
cannibals and sit on the [ __ ] piano
while he does it who cares chrissy
teigen is just a hot chick listen the
queueing on people I all I try to do is
help you people I really do orb
many of you are schizophrenic many of
you are schizophrenic many of you have a
few of the right ideas and a lot of the
wrong ones and that's a potent
combination and it's quite bad it's
quite bad to have some of the right
ideas and some of the wrong ones and
just go confidently with that not good
so Chrissy Teigen I don't even know who
that she's like a model who married John
Legend she's on social media all the
time and she's a hot chick who just kid
the biggest problems in life listen to
me now you see how I did that with my
voice that means I'm going to a
philosopher mode the biggest problems in
life are people that can't be who they
are rich people that can't just be rich
and try to be like clowns you look at
them with pity and you look on in horror
I've seen rich people on stage like
trying to do it and kids nothing sadder
than watching a rich person fail at
trying to be a clown there's nothing
worse than a hot chick trying to be
funny and relevant and interesting if
you don't have to be she's a hot chick
who's addicted to herself all she does
is post [ __ ] every deleted 60,000
tweets I mean the woman's tweeted like
so many [ __ ] times it'll just be like
I could be I'm eating a taco she can't
handle people not looking at her for
five minutes she doesn't have time to be
a satanic pedophile she's on Twitter all
day so here's the thing she tweeted
things about that show toddlers and cars
it's some of them
weird and some of them are creepy she
tweeted some things about pizza or
whatever nobody knew before Pizza gay
people just liked pizza they didn't know
um I don't like Chrissy Teigen I don't
think she's funny
I think she's annoying I don't like that
she judged a comedy competition on NBC
there's nothing funny about her and and
I don't know why the hell I'm going to
jail over pizza I mean what was that
2013 I mean well it does didn't age well
did names well Tim age well but she
didn't know or she did I don't know I
don't know her okay I don't like I'm not
like hanging out with her and John
Legend but I don't think they're eating
children I don't think her and Jenna if
she was a cannibal it would be the most
interesting thing about her how much
more interesting with this [ __ ] be if
she was eating children which I'm
against but again just on the [ __ ]
what makes people interesting if
somebody said you know that hot [ __ ]
Chrissy Teigen who's for some reason
hosting a comedy show on NBC judging you
telling people who's funny and who's not
funny well and she has a cookware line
and I'm like ish and they would go she's
also a [ __ ] cannibal and I'm like
really really but I don't think she is
she's just trying to be funny and when
people that don't have any perspective
try to be funny they just say things
that are outlandish she's just a hot
girl trying to get attention okay so
what she's talking about
eating human flesh I would love to taste
what a human it's just when hot chicks
talk guys just laugh or whatever they
say anyone Chrissy Teigen her entire
life when she said something like they
just want to eat people guys yeah you're
cool
yeah people you're [ __ ] wild if I
said I want to eat people someone goes
and calls the police so there's a
difference between me and Chrissy Teigen
and how people respond to what we say
she's never had to be accountable for
any word that's ever come out of her
mouth she just hasn't because she's
gotten that hot chick or just
nerrac animals what a great song though
why not do that
he's just playing in the piano what a
son Eric animals we just wanna eat off
feel just maybe lean into it I don't
know I don't know I don't think she's
eating chill why do we why do the kids
have why is sexual abuse not enough for
the cue and I'm pitbull why is it not
enough that the kids are being sexually
abused that is heinous horrific should
be like punishable by death why is that
not enough why do they have to be eating
the children I don't understand why this
has to be a Hansel and Gretel fairy tale
for anyone to care about this is what
I've seen it just Lane doing was that
somehow better because they weren't
barbecuing the girls after I don't
understand do you have to bring out a
human-sized rotisserie for people to
care about children is very strange very
strange to me this obsession with the
celebrities being cannibals I think if
you just have a very shitty life or your
board and your life's actually pretty
good but you're bored you just start
thinking that everybody who's achieved
any level of success eats people I don't
know what breaks in your mind I don't
know what happens is chrissy teigen in
the illuminati how embarrassing is it if
this [ __ ] is the thing that you all
think like can you imagine doesn't that
bother some of you that it's this woman
a woman who gets in cookware feuds with
other with the food bloggers but I think
she should probably get off Twitter or
take a little break Chrissy you're not
built for it relax she's big on Twitter
I sub tweeted her once it said something
and people are like whoa don't [ __ ]
around with Chrissy
they said she'll get you thrown right
off Twitter and I said why I said I'm
just an ordinary cannibal
[Music]